[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's bring in sean salisbury the
great morning host sean salisbury show
on sports talk 790
in houston somebody's somebody's got to
win the nfc east
right dad you're giving those numbers
out like it's a team i quarterback
sean salisbury's 411 in one team makes
the playoffs
it is you know and every one of them's
got something to like but a lot of them
got something to hate and a whole lot to
dislike
i i and i know uh mclovin
is loving it the fact that his team
could very well like you said host a
playoff game but
i my gut tells me just a hunch
that there'll be an early out okay it's
just just a hunch i know but it's always
weird like that sean where we go that
team
somebody is going to have 10 wins and be
on the road in the playoffs to face
the eagles or the giants or washington
or dallas whoever it might be
and strange things happen when you get
to the playoffs because
that team that struggled just to make it
to the playoffs as opposed to that team
that goes okay
we're going to be a wild card team and
you know those
those teams are dangerous it's like
seattle many years ago when new orleans
had to go to seattle and seattle won
with a seven and nine record
that's exactly right one i remember
there was talk all over the country how
in the world
do we reseed we got to start to change
this we can't have the
the uh seattle seahawks host the game
but
and dan it is because you get to the
point it's like that injury or when we
saw that you know the
jordan situation when he was not feeling
well you kind of take pressure off
yourself because nobody expects you to
win
think about if philadelphia or the
giants are hosting a playoff game
everybody in the world is going to say
vegas they're going to put the line out
there
so as a player you kind of take pressure
off you let it rip you cut it loose
because everything's a bonus
and then they do become dangerous and
they've been under that struggle all
year so they know what adversity looks
like
and then they have a chance to overcome
it and you never let a team
hang around and teams like that that
hang around late in the third quarter in
the fourth quarter
then all of a sudden the favorite starts
to look around say maybe we're not that
good
and you end up losing and it does happen
and you're right that 7-9 seattle team
took care of their business at home uh
against new orleans and also
the difference though this year is there
really is no home field advantage so
that'll be
beneficial for the team traveling why is
the national media fascinated
with carson wentz
good guy um not a self-promoter
uh i was i was thinking about this the
other day dana if
any other quarterback or most should i
say they'd be
he will he wouldn't be playing most of
the time now the fact that they have a
backup who's a rookie
who i we know is a winner but you paid
him a lot
uh and carson doesn't really bother
anybody damn what's not to like he came
in as the underdog remember even though
he's a high draft pick
comes out of north dakota state so he's
kind of like oh small school guys so you
kind of root for that
but why you know you're right jalen
hurts why did they draft him
well why would the you know you got the
redskins or
the washington football team now you
take robert griffin and deshanna you
know
mike liked uh kirk cousins as well ain't
nothing wrong with that we we draft two
linemen why the hell can't we draft two
quarterbacks so
to me it's a second round pick though
that you use
right dan i'll tell you why because that
ought to tell you how they feel about
him they didn't draft him to move him to
slot or wide receiver or
running back jalen hurts is a
quarterback and i think he proved by
going to lincoln riley
that oh we know he's a winner it's
alabama under the saban
umbrella well he goes to lincoln riley
and boom he proves that he can still win
and still throw it i actually love the
draft pick because it's either going to
bring out the best in carson wentz or
unfortunately
whether it's jalen hurts or not bringing
out the worst i didn't think carson's a
good guy
people root for but he's playing missing
easy throws the mechanics
are horrendous and it seems to me like
he's always a split second late and when
you're pulling when you're not pulling
the trigger on open throws
then that's a problem i will not be
shocked if this continues that if jalen
hurts doesn't get
legitimate run and i root for carson
wentz like everybody else does
but he's not above criticism he is not
playing good football would you rather a
baker mayfield or carson wins
right now right now the way a place not
even close he'd rather have baker
mayfield now
if like if you told me sean carson wentz
is going to get that
swagger or that feel back that he had
when he got hurt when they went to the
super bowl
that i'm going to get that carson wentz
well then i'm taking that carson wins
but dan
sometimes you hit the yips like you know
whether it's putting or whether it's
throwing the football
or me when you have the yips in an
entire 10-year career that you just try
to fight through it right
is it's hard to overcome and he's in a
very difficult
intelligent passionate football town and
when that stuff starts to creep in it's
tough to get it out regardless what he
says he's not bothered by the trade talk
no human being can't be bothered so i i
personally today i want baker mayfield
because he's got a winning team he's
starting to feel it
if you told me i was going to get the
old carson wince well i'm taking the old
carson wins right now
it's a no-brainer i'm not sure i'm not
taking jalen hurts over carson when's
the way he's playing right now
sean salisbury morning host to the sean
salisbury show and sports talk 790 in
houston of course former
nfl quarterback what is the difference
with desean watson in the last six games
a big part of the question going in for
me dan and i think a lot of people
wonder what will desean watson do when
he loses the crutch to lean on in
deandre hopkins well we've seen it their
passing offense has not suffered matter
of fact
he's gotten better i always had a
problem with him
enormous talent great player the hero
syndrome that he wasn't willing not to
make every play
and the best quarterbacks i've ever been
around know when
throwing it out of the back of the end
zone when not to take a sack now i don't
want to teach the hero part out of him
but the last two weeks i've watched him
one time in two weeks go in the red zone
scrambles out
not there throws it out of the back of
the end zone the watson i saw in the
past would have tried to make some
spectacular play
and he's used to two or three clunkers a
year it's like what are you thinking
he hasn't had one of those this year the
distribution of the football
i think he's confident with tim kelly
and this is on a team when they're not
playing well if the
if their situation was reversed and they
were seven and four
he'd be in the mvp talk he's having a
marvelous year but it's his ability
to know when to throw it away he's
making the simple play
the the big home run dan the the you
know the grand slam's always there he's
learning better how to hit singles
the flats open get it out now don't pass
up an open receiver
to hope that you got a home run and in
the process of his
unbelievable ability the home runs
coming so
and they push the ball down the field
and he's taken calculated smart chances
and he's maturing good gracious he's had
an another coordinator
so he's starting to settle into the
position on a team that isn't real good
and they're allowing him to set his feet
because even though they don't run it
well
the offensive line does pass protect
well he is he's going to be an mvp guy
for a long time
and he makes people around him better
and he's also making himself better by
knowing when to throw the ball away and
that you can't make every play
and i wonder and i've always felt that
he held on to the ball too long and you
know no
question and yep yeah and the smart ones
uh you know they they get the ball away
to live to see another day
but i'm also curious has eric the enemy
like it felt like romeo cornell might
get this job
somehow because you know during this
pandemic and trying to get candidates in
and whatever it might be
if you're eric be enemy and you know
houston's open
the jets probably is going to be open
maybe the bears will be open i mean it's
probably going to be four or five
openings here if eric b enemy is who we
think he is
offensive minded would you rather go
with deshawn watson
with what you've seen or go to the jets
with
you know you're going to get trevor
lawrence would you go to jacksonville
with justin fields would you go to
chicago with
whoever i always want
the proven elite quarterback that's
young as opposed to the what might be
remember sam darnold was supposed to be
that guy
and unfortunately he's been coached
poorly so while trevor lawrence is what
we call a
what generational it seems like every
year though a generational guy
but how is sam darnold coach poorly i
mean now gays came out and said look i
i made a mistake how do you well i don't
like the way they go about their
business offensively play calling i just
don't i could
dan we would if we were sitting at a you
know show in an hour we could talk about
it
i just and i'll tell you what let's face
facts darling's not above this criticism
he forces too many balls and the part of
being a great quarterback and you
mentioned
like in my homes and rogers and and and
watson hold the ball tonight
those great ones throw the ball away and
know when not to take a sack
darnold's idea is my arm's so good i'll
just hey we're on 011 let me take
another shot and he did it at sc
he just had better players at sc at
times so i think
coached but i don't think donald's made
the progress nessie look at lamar
jackson's growth
before this year look at what josh
allen's done so coaching does matter but
you've got to process the information
but back to
if i'm derrick the enemy i always take i
don't want to take well what if trevor
lawrence is good
well what if and he may be spectacular
or what if
you know fields is spectacular i got a
25 year old making 40 million bucks or
close to it a year
who's on a bad football team that loads
you on his shoulders
has proven it he's got national
championship that type of dna
and everybody loved there's nothing he
can't do why would i
the only thing for me is are you
concerned about the consistency and the
commitment
of the ownership because if you're just
talking quarterback yeah
i'm not taking the one that could be i'm
taking the one that is and deshawn
watson's one of the five best at his
position
in the league and he's showing it week
to week what's the local reaction to
john wall for russell westbrook
lateral move i think people here feel
like you lost an all-around better
player
but you got better as a team and coach
silas said yesterday dan in his presser
and it was i was listening to you
earlier talk about how the chemistry is
going to work and they were talking
about fit and he said
well it's going to be interesting it'd
be great when john wall pushes the ball
up the floor like he's done in his
career
and gets the ball to guys on the wings
and i'm thinking is james listening to
this
that john walls gonna be pushing it but
i think fans we
wanted to change and we know that when
james wants a change
that it happens well every year you're
on a one-year contract when you're a
star that comes here
but hey this franchise was stagnant
getting to the playoffs wasn't enough
why not try something different since
there's a lot of if stan
if boogie cousins is healthy if john
wall's healthy after being out two years
so
i think the fans here are ready for it
and i think that
i i honestly don't think that it was a
big deal for them we lost russ
it's like oh well we still got james we
got some new ones got a new coach let's
see how
this one works and we'll see what john
wall is bringing after two years of
being out but
he looks explosive in some of his
workouts but lateral move for most of
the people here
but if it's true that james harden
preferred john wall
can he say that you get rid of westbrook
and then james harden still wants out
like why am i
i don't give a damn what james harden
wants i have to look at what what's good
for the rockets if james doesn't want to
be there
i don't care if you like john wall or
not and i and
i'm hoping that coach silas has this
it's one thing to to you know
we know about catering to superstars and
there's no sport in the world
that caters to their stars more than the
nba but i can tell you this i'm hoping
that silas says
as he mentioned i'm going gonna give him
his space but we're gonna run the
offense like
i wanna do it and we're gonna try to
maximize everybody's bill i'm with you
dan
nobody other than lebron james i'm
telling you nobody on a professional nba
franchise
has more pull or has had more pull with
when the flight charter leaves to go on
a trip
than james harden lebron and james in
that order as far as
pull within their organization well
daryl murray's gone now they haven't won
an nba title so i think people are
starting to wear thin on
great offensive player great player but
i don't care either you're either going
to buy in
or we're going to move you and if you
don't want to be here i can get a bunch
of assets for you so we'll see
what james harden shows up you know he's
going to score dan but
after a year what does that mean john
wall's gone next year so it's getting to
the point now
where people are growing a little tired
of it because everything's james wants
james gets
how about returning that with enjoying
it getting in
following suit and putting a ring on
somebody's finger people here aren't
sure that's going to happen
have a great weekend always great to
talk to you buddy great to talk to you
too buddy thank you for having me that's
sean salsberry morning host of the sean
salisbury show sports talk 790
in houston